there's a scene that's quite memorable
in the movie where your character
becomes aroused while wearing underwear
onstage as a tent pitches a tent and
then there's been a lot of chatter as
there is when something like this occurs
in a film was that how was it done was
it was it was that real my question is
was it a prosthetic and if so where can
I get one well I'm in the scene with
Naomi Watts so right exams that there's
that and method actor that I am it's
your craft I I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
a magician shouldn't reveal you know how
the trick is done and I'm not gonna do
that either
especially a the owner the great boner
edition
[Applause]
you know it brought to mind the the you
know within the lore of Hollywood there
are there is the there they're stories
of whose famously well-endowed I know
and you know that I'm just trying to
live my life I've done the show number
times I always wondered why your desk
was set so much higher than hold it down
welded to the floor that knocking
knocking no but but you know Harvey
Keitel who I worked with on a film once
told me that when Willem Dafoe who is
often mentioned in those kinds of the
club's
well-endowed men yeah he told me that
when they did the Last Temptation of
Christ together and Willem had to be
lifted once bolted to the cross that he
you know kind of came out of his loin
cloth and because his hands were stuck
right said guys I'm gonna need some help
and Harvey swore to me that a grip an
electrician turned and said is that
props or animal Wrangler
[Applause]
you